first of all ladies and gentlemen let us
wish a warm welcome back to our beloved
Dennis Leske who in the alternate
timeline is kind of a dick but we'll get
to him in a moment for we have far more
pressing issues in this episode to get
to so let's begin we start by hovering
over the wreckage of a Down helicopter
accompanied by Matthew Devers voiceover
whoo exclaims Castle Rock is being
punished for its sins just like Sodom
and Gomorrah Sodom and Gomorrah being
sinful cities in the Bible that were
ravaged by God through fire and
brimstone
just like how Castle Rock was engulfed
in flames in Episode five we bear
witness to some gruesome events from
castle rocks past including a school bus
getting destroyed by a train and a
funeral passing over Pangborn bridge
with kids wearing the same type of mass
like the townspeople wore during the
fire in Episode five Matthew's voiceover
recounts the story of his mother trying
to kill him as a baby with a wooden coat
hanger convinced that the devil has
ahold of him but God brought him back so
Matthew decided to dedicate every day of
his life to him
remember what Ruth says nothing stays
dead in this town Matthew then spouts
the same narration that day Lacey said
in Episode two that God doesn't take
requests and that he waited years for
instructions like Lacey he assembled a
cage and you can note the acts and light
bulb we've seen in Henry's flashbacks
from previous episodes after the title
credits were transported to Boston where
we find the kid going for a run well
later find out this is an alternate
timeline but we'll get to that in a bit
he's getting ready for a big
presentation and we see him eating
something other than Wonder Bread for
the first time implying that we are
indeed not in the time or universe we've
been watching for the majority of the
series he picks up a note reading break
a brain today love em em likely
referring to his wife slash girlfriend
Maren who we'll meet later the kid
lectures on the idea of continuity and
how when continuity is disrupted can
lead to dementia he tells the people
that he's discovered a cure for
Alzheimer's by use of an implant an
implant which has helped a cat named
puck the same name as ruse dog
apparently this chip can unscramble the
brain to make people remember
if you recall in episode 5 Alan says why
don't you just put a chip in her like a
golden retriever this also makes the
events at the end of that episode more
powerful when the kid tells Alan he can
fix Ruth he means he can literally fix
her by putting a chip in her walking
with Marron the kid gets a call from
surprise surprise Alan Pangborn in this
timeline Alan is alive and well the same
can't be said for the kid's father who
Alan tells him has just passed away the
kid arrives crossing over the Pangborn
bridge where we see a markedly different
Castle Rock people are out celebrating
the fall harvest festival as the kid
passes the castle rock called newspaper
and the Emporium galore iam run by
Reginald Merrill mentioned in Kings
needful things we even get to see the
improved mellow Tiger gastropub in
vibrant downtown which now boasts a
sushi and ramen shop outside the town
square are two more King references
Sheldon stationary referring to Paul
Sheldon from Stephen King's misery and
Claiborne Creamery referring to Dolores
Claiborne coincidentally both film
adaptations feature Kathy Bates the kid
stops for a moment outside the church
notice the sign of the Duchamp Meryl
marriage both characters from King's the
body he heads outside the Deever home
with his bag just like Henry did an
episode one using the key located under
the Frog that young male used in episode
three the house looks in complete
disrepair with private property signs
and an uncapped lawn out front and
inside is no better looking like an
episode of Hoarders random knick knacks
newspapers and religious paraphernalia
are strewn about the home the kid
experiences a flashback of his father
preaching a line from corinthians death
is swallowed up in victory Corinthians
having come up in almost every episode
to date in Henry's old room the kid
looks across the street at Molly's house
and experiences a flashback of Molly's
flashlight something only Henry has
taken part in so far hinting another
link between Henry and the kid he meets
Bridget who you may recall as Molly's
sister from episode 2 she thinks he's a
real estate agent who's scanned the
obituaries to get a jump on castle rocks
bustling real estate market a big
contrast to the rundown Castle Rock
we've seen in the other timeline
Bridget tells him that the guy who owned
the
house blew his head off by the lake just
like de Lacy but he had a different
method Mali appears and remembers the
kid calling him by his real name
Henry Deaver yes we finally get to know
that the kid is Matthew and Bruce son in
an alternate timeline now for the
purposes of the remaining videos I'm
still going to call the kid the kid and
not Henry so that all our heads don't
pull a Matthew Deaver and explode from
confusion if you remember back to
episode 6 that Henry told his son
Wendell that Ruth and Matthews
biological son died during childbirth
but in this timeline he's alive and well
the kid and Molly go to the Mellow Tiger
gastropub where everyone in town seems
to know Molly they all say hi to her
unlike the other timeline where she's
thought of as a crazy person the kid
even jokes that she's like the mayor but
she tells us she's just a Council Chair
her sister Bridget is the one screwed up
in this timeline which is a fun reversal
the kid gives us some interesting
information that his mother Ruth lives
in Sarasota with Allen Allen convinced
Ruth to leave Matthew in this timeline
and she left him and moved with the kid
the kid even refers to their love as
star-crossed a reference to Romeo and
Juliet who both spoiler alert died in
the end to engrossing Maren calls as the
kid enters the deeper home and the
lights go out he inquires if she's taken
the pregnancy test yet as he
investigates the fuse box we see the
kids shoe which was one of the flashes
Henry experienced in Episode four then
another huge moment the kid finds young
Henry in the cage so Leske is back and
it looks like he's in charge of
investigating this case he asked when
the last time the kid talked to his
father which was when he was about young
Henry's age apparently young Henry is
saying his name is Henry Deaver just
like when the kid called himself that in
episode 1 Celestia straight up if his
father touched him trying to draw a
connection with a priest having a little
boy locked in his basement we learned
that in both timelines Matthew heard the
voices in the woods and that he brought
his kid out there in the hopes that he
would hear it young Henry hearing the
sound of the skismo makes a break for
the woods but is quickly caught whatever
is in the woods is beckoning him back
the kid listens to a tape of Matthew
going over all the bad things that have
happened
I'll rock the tape says weak 1437 which
if you do the math is roughly 27 years
since he started the amount of years the
kid was apparently locked up in the shed
he finds hundreds of tapes
one in particular asking if the bad
patch of events started with the French
settlers hundreds of years ago and the
story of a young girl forced to carve up
her family and eat them to stay alive
during the freezing cold in the woods
the kid uncovers what appears to be the
anechoic chamber his father tried to
build the one Odin told Henry about an
episode six
apparently Matthew found young Henry in
the woods he had blacked out after
hearing the skismo so loud he reappeared
in this new timeline a new time l'amour
no one knew who he was
Matthew believing young Henry to be the
devil drugs him and locks him in the
cage even calling him the deceiver which
sounds really close to Deaver the kid
shows Molly the tapes and the two of
them try to piece the puzzle together
according to Matthew young Henry was
down there for 27 years and didn't aged
a day just like the kid Matthew taught
him how to carve soap figurines like the
ones we've seen in previous episodes
then he recites lines eerily similar to
what Dale Lacey wrote to Alan Pangborn
stating as long as the devil walks the
streets of Castle Rock tragedy after
tragedy will pile up Molly says she can
find out where they took him using her
superpowers as castle rock council chair
notice how she's wearing the same jacket
from episode 8 where she appears bloody
in the forest an entourage of ambulance
and fire trucks rush past them
foreshadowing the fire that we see as
overtaking the hospital where young
Henry was staying at killing 7 in the
process to make matters worse the cops
think Henry did it in fact he's even
confessed to it molly is able to
question Henry and asked him why he
started the fire to which he explains
the boy in the bed next to him got too
close who or what this boy is remains to
be seen but it could have something to
do with the link to the other timeline
remember the fire at juniper Hill
started when the inmates apparently lit
their own mattresses on fire it's
possible he was seeing something from a
different timeline the skismo gets
louder and Henry goes frantic saying
they have to get to the woods
Molly touches him and experiences
flashes of the alternate
malee likely because she's the coolest
chair council in the land is able to
take the suspected arsonist home as long
as officers Alessi follows and keeps an
eye on them
Molly experiences more flashbacks this
time her killing Matthew in the other
timeline she exclaims that she has to
take young Henry to the woods and boots
the car to train crossing leaving
Zaleski behind Henry makes a run for the
woods and we see the images of him
running from previous episodes are not
of him being chased by his father but by
the kid in Molly
Henry stops in a small clearing where
he's transported into what is likely a
thinny from the Dark Tower series my
apologies if it's actually pronounced
tinny I'm not exactly sure so bear with
me the force acts as one a weak spot
where the fabric of the world has been
worn thin and reality has eroded away
the knees have the appearance of a
silver green fog and amid a highly
unpleasant sound yet will lure nearby
people in this space acts as a rift
between the two timelines and perhaps
countless others here Henry witnesses a
woman in period clothing holding a
bloody knife this is likely the French
settler who carved her family up and ate
them that Matthew talked about when
Molly touches Henry she is also
transported to this plain and to make
matters worse Zaleski shows up with his
gun drawn what is with him and drawing
his gun all the time back with Molly we
see more Ravens who haven't had a good
time so far on Castle Rock Henry chases
after the woman and Molly follows but is
soon shot by what appears to be Dennis
he does have a history of shooting
people but how she got shot is still a
mystery
so Leske clearly shot in the air and
nowhere near her one theory is that the
bending of space and time in this
particular area warped the bullet so
that when Zaleski fired it's somehow
shot her another theory is that she was
actually shot by the prison guards
chasing after the escapees seen here
molly pleads to the kid to help henry
and when he touches her he is also
somehow transported to the thinny
whatever this place is it's not a good
one we see a woman cutting her arms note
the piece of jewelry on her finger and
blood similar to what Henry saw an
anechoic chamber some claim this woman
is the French woman in a different
timeline but I'm not convinced here they
are side by side for those who would
like to compare everything crescendos
and the kids suddenly wakes
in winter he travels to the bluffs atop
Castle Lake the same place where Lacey
drove his car off in Episode one to
witness Alan Pangborn rescuing Henry in
1991 the kid has somehow managed to
travel from his timeline through the
rift and out the other end in Henry's
timeline the one we've been watching
since episode 1
he tells Molly that he wandered around
for days but couldn't get back until
Lacey found him and took him to show
Shane that Lacey quote heard the call
and that the kid was the devil episode 9
ends the same way 8 did with the kid
saying you believe me don't you but
Dewey is the kid in this timeline a
reliable narrator is he telling us the
truth or is it all a lie what we do know
is that bad stuff has happened as a
result of these timelines being messed
up and whoever switches doesn't seem to
age my prediction for next episode is
that the kid will likely get back to his
own timeline 11 days Willow past just
like the eleven days when young Henry
was discovered and that he'll find out
his wife is pregnant and maybe even call
him Alan Deaver but this will likely
mean that he'll also have forgotten that
complete 27 years he was locked up just
like young Henry when he reappeared and
don't count out that chip coming into
play I hope you'll tune in next week for
my final Castle Rock episode and let me
know which show to do next in the
comments below as always if you liked
this video make sure to LIKE and
subscribe see you all next week